[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
bye
[Music]
so
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
now yeah
good afternoon
sparsely attended because it caught you
unaware i said next week
monday wednesday friday this week
spontaneity still works
today day 278
update on the numbers because the
numbers are changing
positivity in micro clusters 5.91
statewide positivity with our micro
clusters 4.49
with micro clusters 4.8
over 200 000 tests which is a lot of
tests
61 new york has passed away there are no
thoughts and prayers
139 up on hospitalization 41 up on
icu for up on intubation
it's all about hospitalizations
hospitalization rate
hospitalization capacity over the last
three days okay
that's how many people entered the
hospitals
from those areas over the last
three days southern tier
has done really remarkably well
since we had that problem i think it
really uh
communicated to people
this is changing hospitals over the past
week
okay past seven days
new york city up 249.
long island 181 finger lakes 142 mid
hudson 123.
obviously highest number in new york
city
so really you want to look at this
compared
to the population in that area
right yes you're going to get more
people out of new york city because new
york city
has 9 million people
this is the hospitalization by
percentage of the region
which i think is probably the most
uh telling tale
western new york and finger lakes both
have
.03
of their populations hospitalized 0.03
you then get to central new york mohawk
valley mid-hudson
long island southern tier capital region
you're at 0.02
new york city north country .01
got it uh that is
how many people are hospitalized as a
percentage
of that population
and that is i think probably the most
relevant chart right now
in the broad scope of things
we're dealing with hospitalizations and
increases
we are doing dramatically better
than virtually every other state in the
country
uh who's doing better maine vermont and
hawaii
maine vermont and hawaii are in a
different situation than new york
less population less cities lost density
etc
we have been going back and forth with
massachusetts but massachusetts now
is higher than new york is today
total scope of things total number of
hospital beds in the state
is what 53 000.
hold a second go back so totally
accurate 53
000 until we what
we flex of the flex and surge
we can increase the 53 000 beds up to 75
000 beds which we did last time right we
added 50 000 beds do you remember that
how many beds are currently occupied 35
000 beds
how many beds are currently occupied
with covert patients 4063
so that's the dimensions that we're
dealing with
we're dealing with hospitalization rate
hospitalization capacity
you start with 53 000 beds you can
end elective surgery reduce the number
of people who are in those beds
you can expand the system
it's difficult but you can do it we did
it last time by 50
percent that brought you to about 75 000
beds
today 4 000 people hospitalized with
covert
at our height how many people did we
have hospitalized
with covid at our peak
about nineteen thousand just to put all
these numbers in perspective
the legislature passed a
rent assistance bill
the rent assistance bill appropriated
100 million dollars
up to 100 million dollars and
but had eligibility requirements
on what income levels could qualify
we ran the program the number of
eligible applicants
only brought us to 40 million dollars
in rental aid
by the parameters of the law
by executive order i'm going to change
the law
spoken to the legislative leaders about
this
reopen the application window extend the
eligibility requirements
to help more new yorkers
washington is considering
passage of a bill
which would help with state and local
financing
unemployment insurance transportation
aid vaccination funding etc
they have been going back and forth
speaker pelosi put forth the heroes bill
months ago they were then talking about
a possible compromise bill
senator mcconnell has been
extraordinarily difficult his statement
was let the states go bankrupt
50 states go bankrupt that's bad for the
country
because the country is 50 states
um senator manchin
has proposed basically a bipartisan
compromise bill
of 908 billion dollars
i spoke to senator manchin
explained his reasoning which i think
is sound i spoke with speaker pelosi
i agree that as governor of new york
that we need help desperately
and something is better than nothing
and as a first down payment i
urge them to get something done before
they leave
for christmas
families will not have a holiday if they
don't act
and if there isn't some aid
senator president-elect biden
also urged them to get something done
senator manchin who i have great respect
for by the way
says that he believes this is the best
they can get done again it's
a first down payment it doesn't come
near to the need
it would be a short-term bill until
march
and i would urge them uh to get this
first
down payment bill passed before they
leave
just so families have funding for the
holiday season and it takes some
pressure off state local governments
they would then have to come back and do
a real bill
next year
i'm sorry also as chairman of the
national governors
association national governors
association we
asked for 500 billion dollars in state
and local funding
national governors association that's
democrats and republicans
we sent a letter supporting a 500
billion dollar state and local package
this bill has 160 billion dollars in
state and local funding
uh so it's it's not nearly what
the governor's asked for of this country
but again uh something
is better than nothing and uh we would
support a first
down payment bill the
next chapter is going to be vaccine
distribution and vaccine acceptance
this is the weapon
that wins the covid war
and we have to get serious about this
the distribution is a massive
undertaking by government
i've said a number of times it has to be
fair it has to be equitable
the state has to have funding to do it
we have to be able to get the black and
brown communities
and poor communities
blacks died at twice the rate that
whites died browns died at one and a
half times the rate
that whites died they've had less covert
testing they have higher infection rates
there is no justification
not to have a very aggressive outreach
program
for the black and brown community but
government is going to have to do its
part
people are also going to have to do
their part they're going to have to
accept this vaccine
and right now all the current data
suggests people are very skeptical about
the vaccine
and the estimates are you need about 75
of the population to be vaccinated for
it to be effective
and uh you have 50
of the population roughly saying they're
not going to take the vaccine
mathematically that doesn't work you
can't get to 75 percent the 50 percent
say they're
they aren't going to take it but this is
here and now
this vaccine distribution is going to
happen in the next couple of weeks
new york state is going to be very
aggressive about the distribution
i believe there's a great advantage to
the state that
most effectively vaccinates all people
and we'll be reaching out and educating
people in the state
i would never ask anyone in the state to
take a vaccine that i was unwilling to
take myself
that's always been my standard i'm not
asking you to send your child to school
if i wouldn't send my child to school
i'm not asking you to put yourself in a
situation that i wouldn't put myself
and i won't ask new yorkers to take a
vaccine that i wouldn't take myself
but it is real and we need people to
start to focus on it
because we want to get it done very
quickly and i want
new yorkers to start to think about it
seriously
we're not going to get to the general
population for a while
but you will start with not for nursing
home
distribution so you'll have parents
asking their family what do you think
should i take it or not
you'll have health care staff uh having
to decide whether or not they take it
and people should start focusing on it
because it's real
and it's here and again new york wants
to do it
as quickly as we can just to show you
how real
it is
in this box what is in this box
maybe it's a christmas present
who would i give a christmas present to
at this point
let's not ask this is a
box of vaccines
pfizer which is a great new york company
uh made the vaccine pfizer developed the
vaccine
without any assistance from the federal
government
they did it all on their own uh and
we're very proud to call them into your
company but it's a
the vaccine process
is uh a complicated
process and the distribution
is uh going to take a lot of work and a
lot of effort
the package itself comes with
a geo
tracker gps tracking device
that can track the
and a thermal
monitor so it monitors the temperature
of the package you want to know where
the package is
and the package has to stay at the right
temperature
because if it doesn't then the vaccine
is destroyed
it comes in wrapped in dry ice
the dry ice because it has to be
ultra cold when you receive the package
you have to replace
the dry ice and then you have to replace
the dry ice
every five days okay
under the dry ice
is the actual package that has
uh the trays in it
the trays have the actual
vials
a vial by the way the vials
are made glass
from corning glass another great new
york company
a vial contains enough for five
dosages the vial comes
with a diluting liquid
and the the actual vial gets diluted
before the uh
before the vaccination actually happens
one
tray they call this a tray one
tray can hold up to
195 vials
each vial this is a vial
can do five dosages
the package itself can hold five
trays so roughly 5
000 dosages could be in this one box
the storage and handling of the box
itself
is complicated you can only open the box
two times a day for 60
to 90 seconds each time
because keeping it at the right
temperature is very important
so it's either in ultra cold storage or
it has dry
ice but then you can only open it twice
a day for 60 seconds
to 90 seconds uh each time
when you actually do the vaccine you
take out the vial
the vial is frozen you have to
allow the vial to thaw at room
temperature for about 30 minutes
you then dilute the vial
for and let it stand for two hours
and then you have six hours to
administer
the dosage okay so this is a complicated
procedure that's one dosage and then the
person has to come
back and receive the second dosage about
21 days later
so the package comes it either has to be
stored in ultra cold
storage or the dry ice is replaced and
the dry ice
can keep it up to five thousand dosages
five dosages per diet per
vial and
then there's a procedure to dethaw the
vial
dilute the dosage and then
administer the dosage within six hours
thereafter and that's one dosage
second dosage is 21 days later and
the person is not the vaccine really
isn't
effective until after the second dosage
so it's it's not
easy but it's real
and they're being manufactured and
they're going to be shipped
and we're very proud of pfizer and we're
proud of corning and we are
working very hard to be ready for the
distribution
and training people on the distribution
to make sure it's all done correctly
but this is the weapon
that is going to win the war and that is
the light at the end of the tunnel right
so it's not tomorrow it's not a short
tunnel
but we know the way through this
we just have to get there and we have to
get there
with as little loss of life as possible
questions plan for uh staffing you know
you just talked about how it is a big
concern especially for maybe smaller and
medium-sized hospitals who might not be
able to
tap into staff staffers at other
locations you know what sort of you know
in the spring obviously we had the big
plan to
bring in volunteers from across the
country what sort of
um you know beyond retirees sort of
thing what's sort of the plan to help
with that issue we have the surgeon
flex system which deals with hospital
capacity
hospital capacity has several elements
within it
number of beds availability of equipment
availability of staff
they're all in the capacity
constellation
when you run into a problem with
capacity
then you have the ability to actually
flex
from different hospital systems so if
one hospital system is in trouble
because they're running out of capacity
for any of the three elements
beds equipment staffing then you can
shift
to another hospital system
is this a mock-up presumably or is this
so this is actual vaccine that you have
up there
i will give you the first one if you
come here i will be the first one to
administer
under doctor supervision
i'm going to also put some of this new
york clean
in the vaccine which will have the added
benefit
of cleaning your arteries while you're
being treated by the vaccine
we can do it all at the same time
real quick there is no vaccine in this
vial it is a vial but it is without
vaccine contact the focuser is the hot
spots
but i didn't want to tell him that he's
going to put this in the vial
and inject it into his own clean up his
act
so going back to the focus zones at this
point i've lost count i believe
there's 22 or so that are above 5
do you feel that the state has moved
from kind of a containment strategy at
this point to a mitigation strategy
that's part of the second way i don't
know that really containment
mitigation uh
are applicable anymore jesse those were
sort of terms they used early on
we are trying to contain we are trying
to mitigate
uh we've been doing both right reduce
the spread
flatten the curve uh but also contain it
so i think we've we've been pursuing
both strategies now
from the get-go
but you're seeing there's no doubt using
a nationwide global increase in the
overall numbers
and then it depends on how you want to
argue it new york is seeing
much less of an increase than other
states but
we're still seeing an increase the
hotspot strategy the micro clusters
has worked has that been a success
considering the kind of spread of it oh
yeah
oh yes look you're not going to do i
think we're going to defy
human nature and
global dynamics no
um you're into the holiday season
uh you're seeing the same thing all
across the world now
defy is a funny world word has new york
defied
the dynamic more than other states
yes has it divided
in total no you know it has defied it
because that's the johns hopkins can you
put up johns hopkins again
this is the johns hopkins chart
shows new york has defied
the national surge right otherwise new
york would have to be up there
with idaho and kansas and south dakota
hasn't defied it absolutely but it has
largely that's why we're all the way at
the bottom the micro clusters
is because we have so much data
much more data than any other state
because we have so many tests
we know exactly where people live
so from a medical point of view you can
target much more closely
and you can
target the medical resources so you're
not
chasing all over the state you know it's
this community
and to the extent you have to do
economic restrictions it's just this
community you don't have to close
a restaurant in queens because you have
a problem in brooklyn
you don't have to close a restaurant in
utica because you have a problem in
albany what is the token though
when you talk about the using
hospitalization rates as a
new metric right to establish these
zones
are you at all concerned about waiting
this kind of seven to ten days after
thanksgiving
once again this is a virus that has
shown itself to be very effective in
spreading
a couple of days can make a difference
are you worried about changing those
metrics
that far taking that much time to change
the metrics well
we're adding we're adding the
hospitalization rate to the uh factors
right
but where we are now the hospitalization
is most important
are you going to see the infection rate
increase yes
you're going to see it continue to
increase i believe all through the
hospital season
uh you talk to people like dr fauci the
cdc experts they all say the same thing
i guess the question is if the
restrictions are pegged to orange
red red yellow zones they're on
businesses and things like that
and we're waiting an extra seven to ten
days to restrict those things
while we kind of assemble data post
thanksgiving is that waiting too long
well we have restricted them
and here's the real problem
the valve analogy and restricting
slowing the spread at one time you
control to a large extent
activity that was causing the spread
at this point you don't control
the overwhelming majority of the
activity causing the spread
because over 70 of the spread
is beyond your control it's in small
gatherings
it's in household parties uh it was at
the thanksgiving table
government cannot control that
the gyms salons the protocols are
working
they're a very small percentage of
increase
restaurants bars for a second you said
70 percent of the indoor gatherings but
then
when we spoke to rob yesterday he said
that's only the 70
of the 20 that you've been able to
contact trace but that's actually really
verifiable only 14 that we know are
coming from indoors
you're extrapolating to the whole 20 is
the
20 of the contact
tracing is the
uh database which is
tens of thousands of points of data how
many people is the 20
do you remember what was it 40 30
000 you have 30 000 data points
30 000 data points is a large sample
uh you know they take it you take a
statewide sample you do 500 people you
extrapolate to the state
right you do 500 people you can
extrapolate to the nation
uh you have 30 000 data points
that's a lot of data to extrapolate from
let's do someone else first can we just
your electricity
how can you say that's a representative
sample or not
i said thirty thousand is a very large
sample
really is just to justin's point you
can't really necessarily say that's a
representative sample to completely rule
out any spread from
you know any businesses that are still
open or indoor dining
well 30 000 i think anybody would say
is a very very large sample
uh to use as a reference point
i mean thirty thousand do you know
anything else that has a database of
thirty thousand
um i do know that the when it comes to
do you have a question
yes i have uh one on vaccines and one on
nursing homes
uh first of all on the vaccine you said
that you wouldn't ask anyone to take the
vaccine that you would pick yourself
will you take the vaccine will you do it
like you did with the test
yes next question yes i said that
will you be one of the first will you
take i said that i said i would not take
ask anyone to take a vaccine that i
wouldn't take myself
i said i wouldn't ask anyone to take a
covet test that i wouldn't take myself
the skepticism about vaccines a lot of
folks that we've spoken with they're
concerned that they'll have to take a
vaccine to get on a plane
or that the state will be very strict
and make people take the vaccine
in order to get into a nursing home or
eventually to go to school
do you support uh do you support
measures like that to get on a
plane to travel should you have to take
a vaccine for cocaine we don't control
uh air travel requirements that's a
federal
especially obligation in regards to this
but today we found out about five big
arrests
um of mta workers who made hundreds of
thousands of dollars in overtime hours
they didn't actually work
um actually the mta inspector general
was involved in this
but anyway the arrests are tied to a
federal investigation
um what do you think of this and do you
think that this is a sign of
corruption or mismanagement in the mta i
think there are bad apples
uh in every line of work uh
you have a multiple thousand workforce
you're gonna have people who take
advantage of of the system
uh i was the attorney general in this
state
uh they're are bad bankers there are bad
brokers there are bad lawyers there are
bad doctors there are bad college
presidents
uh and i have no doubt that there are
people who will abuse the system
the question is i also did mta cases
as the attorney general by the way uh on
disability benefits
you have to have a system in place
that can catch the person who
commits fraud there's an old saying
before your time locks keep
honest people honest locks
keep honest people honest
have a system in place where if somebody
defrauds
the system you catch them i said to the
mta
i went to a facility late at night
i spoke about this uh
gentleman named jim dwyer he's a great
columnist was with the new york times uh
really a beautiful guy who have known
for many many years we go to an mta
facility about midnight one night
and people were supposed to be working
and nobody was there nobody was there
we went through the whole place said to
the supervisor you know where are the
employees
uh and this
was supposed to be a camera the camera
was not operating
right so you have to have the systems
in place where people know if i leave
early then i can get caught
and i will get fired and
if you don't have those systems in place
yeah locks keep honest people honest
good last one
though i mean a lot of this overtime
goes back to
further in 2018. how come this hasn't
been rectified prior i mean
again not to say you control the mta but
that has been alleged that you do
you will never you will never
eradicate all bad actors
in any system uh
it's is a lot of money in overtime
that's actually
double what your salary would be yeah
but how many people were was it
five guys five pounds what's how many
employees
of the mta about seventy thousand so
it's five guys you have a seventy
thousand person workforce right
uh they're always going to have bad
apples go ahead
just a couple questions for you um you
talked about hospital beds but do you
know how many icu beds are currently
available
also any comments on the state board of
elections certifying every race today
except for the 22nd congressional
district race
and one more question under normal
circumstances uh the electoral college
would be casting their votes including
yourself here from the capital on
december 14th is that still going to be
happening here or will that be happening
virtually those are all very hard
questions
that i do not know the answers to but we
will try to work them through one at a
time
where do the electors act
i actually don't know we usually do it
in the assembly chamber i'll find or
send a chamber i'll find out and get
back to you how we're doing it this year
nobody knows you have stumped the panel
you win the first vial award
come on up and get the first
what was your second question um any
comments on the state
board of elections certifying every race
except for the 22nd congressional
district race and
do you know how many icu vets you have
uh any comments on the board of
elections certifying except the 22nd
i'm sorry yeah the
i hope they certify the 22nd race i know
it's a close race
but uh great as soon as they can certify
all the races they should how many icu
beds available
dr zucker's going to answer that
question right off the top of his head
well i i could tell you
by some of the regions but we're running
around 20
what do you have this 26 available used
to be 6 000 total
in the near state about 2 300 are
available right now
and there's 377 coveted patients in icu
right now
53 000 that the government
35 000 are currently occupied does that
include the 4 000.
yes if you end elective surgery
the 35 000 comes down right
that's part of the flex and surge uh
you know of the 35 000 summer trauma
emergency who went in many of them are
elective surgery that's why when you
end elective surgery you make more beds
available
so you open capacity that way the 50
mandatory addition to the beds brought
you from 50 to 75
right so that's the flex that you have
on the system
did you answer the full question what
did you say
if you could go over um how many are so
how many
will you need if you go into a second
wave are you guys have
a larger estimate how many icu beds will
the state need
we have six thousand right now total icu
beds in the state
total icu state exact number is 5 976
that's total icu beds in the state of
those
of those 2 1444
are uh available 2144
are available how many of the 2 000
people
are covered people 377. okay
you don't know i think you should
we've looked at the numbers back in
march the percentage of people were
hospitalized for covet
that ended up in the ic was 25 and now
it's down at 19
the people who ended up in the icu who
were hospitalized back in march april at
that time
80 to 95 to 90 ended up intubated
whereas now it's only about 45 to 50
percent that we're in today
as a reflection of a better management
of patients who have
coronavirus and also people coming in
to the hospital probably sooner because
they recognize that they may be ill
so those numbers have obviously improved
from marching out so that
hospital treatment has changed
dramatically
remember the first time it was they went
into a hospital
we needed a ventilator they were
intubated
the number of innovations is way down
they've changed the medical protocol
the number that go to icu is down the
number that is intubated is down and the
number
that died is what's the death rate
yeah eight percent down it's eight
percent down from what
23 death rate was 23
if you went into the hospital it's now
down to eight
percent okay i'm gonna go to work
thank you very much
you